all right joining us now for a reaction
Fox News contributor Leo Terrell and
Deputy Eder editor of red State Kiera
Davis thank you both for joining us um
Leah uh Leo I should say sorry Leo uh I
gotta tell you doesn't it still a lot of
confidence anytime Kamala Harris comes
to the mic and starts explaining U.S
policy
I'll tell you Jason she gave me a
headache because honestly she's Captain
Obvious she doesn't give any insight she
doesn't tell the American public
anything of inform of an informative
nature she has nothing to bring to the
table and I I mean I think it's
embarrassing that we avoid not this
station or not this network but we avoid
the obvious she was selected for the
wrong reason she was selected because of
her gender and her skin color and that
was the only reason she's not qualified
and she has a difficult time trying to
articulate on issues that she doesn't
have any knowledge on and what's
happening is you saw Andrea Mitchell
Andrea Mitchell has an obligation to
challenge her but they won't because
their Shield she shielded by her skin
color and her her gender when she when
she said for example the balloon wasn't
helpful
I mean the blue has feelings what did
she mean by that can she articulate
something of a leech of at least of a
college nature it sounds so rudimentary
as to what she's articulate I don't even
know what she means we shot it down as
you articulated that blue could have
been shot down
before it reached Continental America
but she insults the intelligence Jason
of the American people and I'm sick and
tired of her being basically shielded
because of her gender and identity
that's why you don't pick people on
gender identity you pick People based on
qualifications
Cara what do you think of that because I
mean at one point the vice president
said let us be clear
uh we shut down the balloon because it
needed to be shut down that's not an
explanation of why we shot it down that
just restating the what happened we shot
it down because we needed to shoot it
down but that but the question is why
right oh thank you so much vice
president Harris that is certainly a lot
more clear and let me be clear every
time you hear Kamala Harris say let me
be clear it means she's going to be the
exact opposite but isn't the way she
sounds isn't that very symbolic of this
entire Administration it feels like the
the entire country is in chaos right now
it feels like everything is falling
apart I believe that part of this
disaster of the Spy balloon part of this
story is that our government is not
coordinated our government is not
communicating with each other through
different departments I think there is a
huge uh Chasm between the White House
and every other major department in this
country we have people making decisions
and they're not Consulting other
departments they're not Consulting the
White House they're certainly not
Consulting Kamala Harris I mean the way
she talks is really just symbolic of the
utter state of confusion that the White
House is in right now and our American
government is in right right now and you
know and the sad thing is is her boss is
even worse
yeah Leo look Kamala Harris among the
many duties of the vice president so
demanding that job is she's supposed to
be our borders are she keeps telling us
that climate change is driving people
from all over the wallet place and and
and this is why millions of people are
traveling north of course she doesn't
spend any time with the border patrol
but it is just malpractice
Democrats didn't hold a single hearing
about this crisis on the southern border
for two years and then Jim Jordan gives
them a three-week notice and says all
right we're gonna have a field hearing
on the ground by the border and the
Democrats boycott it what in the world
are we supposed to think about how much
the Democrats care about illegal
immigration immigration and all the
problems that are surrounded they don't
care fentanyl I mean all of these things
are tied together and yet the Democrats
don't even participate in the in a
congressional hearing where both sides
can ask questions
well let's be very clear there's no need
to mislead the viewers they want open
borders Jason they want open border
you've said it she has done absolutely
nothing to secure the Border why first
question law school because they have no
intention on securing the Border we had
a president before them who secure the
Border they want open border they want
the traffic the drug trafficking the sex
trafficking to go by to go through our
Southern border Kamala Harris has no
idea all she's focusing on is
maintaining her position in that number
two slot I have nightmares of the idea
of her being in that number two slot you
know we have an incompetent president
but just think of Kamala Harris in that
number two slot for the next two years
that is the most frightening thing and
as Kara says the entire White House
Administration is off base again gender
and color is the reason why she's the
vice president look at our press
secretary a national embarrassment when
she was talking about NORAD it it's an
embarrassment I'm sick of the Democrats
playing Equity politics and picking
people on race and color that has to
stop and it's quite embarrassing for
those who are of those of those
particular characteristics who are more
qualified
well and I think there is a case to be
made that this is it is somewhat
coordinated particularly as it relates
to the southern border you have
secretary mayarkas saying the border is
secure but it's obviously not yeah the
vice president who's doing absolutely
nothing except traveling to Central
America once and then holding some phone
calls but you know the president at the
State of the Union goes out and talks
about the scourge of fentanyl but where
do they think that fentanyl is created
and then transported and brought across
our borders he talked to the border
patrol it's coming through our porous
Southern border and they're not doing
anything about it so Jim Jordan does the
right thing he's holding a hearing and
no Democrats going to show up by choice
that's got to be a message to the
American people right Cara
absolutely I mean I was infuriated to
hear the president talk like he cares at
all what's happened what's happening at
the border I live in California this is
a border state and we are dealing with
the crushing consequences of of an
unregulated
unmatched drug trade that it's just
flowing across our border so it was
infuriating to him to steal Republican
talking points but then to sit here in
this border state and know that there's
absolutely we're helpless as the
American people we are helpless right
now and it feels it's not just
embarrassing but it's it's also
insulting you know we we elect these
leaders to protect us we might not
always agree on politics but our
national border should be an easy point
of agreement it should be one thing we
can all agree on that if we don't have
borders we don't have a nation but again
I do believe that this is just part I
agree with Leo this is part of the
Democrats plan mean they've always been
open borders but also when they can sow
chaos in our states and our city centers
they take advantage of that chaos Obama
himself pointed out that strategy right
in his now famous quote you never let a
good crisis go to waste and Democrats
can't win on their plans because their
plans suck and they their plans don't
work so what do they do they have to
create crisis so that Americans feel
fear and then Americans vote based on
fear and as you know Jason no good
decisions are made out of fear but we
are living in an America that is being
led by fearful politicians and
politicians who also politic in the
currency of fear
well look it was a horrific a horrific
week for Biden and Harris and the way
they treated those people in Ohio and
Pennsylvania and did not respond I tell
you that is it could be nothing worse
than that I feel for those people there
God bless you I you're dealing with a
horrific tragedy and the federal
government Biden and Harris are
absolutely nowhere Leo and Kara thank
you so much hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else